Are.
And I went to Greg's when the tap out
guys picked me up and he introduced me and
all that, right. But when
you're on the tap out,
show that a reality show that will
mask called Greg and gotten me.
That's how I got involved
with them, right? I cite
motherfuck us.
I left.
Linda Garcia was fighting Roger Ward two
were my best friends, Raj would call it.
That was damn right.
Motherfucking Mexicans drawn down.
I forgot about that fight. Who'd go to
fight pass, right? To bring that up.
Um, are still wildest dude
other men. So do I, man.
And so he calls me like, Cup, I
need you to come down for a week.
Come for one week.
Help me get ready for Roger.
He took the fight on my three weeks notice
something outlandish just like me and
Leonard Do, right? So I go down
there, I literally never left.
When I went down, first day I
walked into the Jacksons and Rashad,
Keith, St Pierre, Joe
Daddy's Stevenson, uh,
I mean the list goes on and on
and on. And I was like, wow,
this is what a real gym is like, this
is what, and they all accepted me.
It was like, I was like in the family,
right? I call, I owned a house in Denver.
I called my grandma. I said, I'm
never coming home. I'm staying here,
sell the house. Right. And
I literally never went home.
She would just slowly come down to visit
me and bring me truckloads of shit.
Right? Literally, I
lived in a closet, man.
Fuck a third as big as this room. We
had a bunk bed, me and Leonard and a,
if one person who was standing up,
the other person had to be in the bed.
That's how small this room was. Wow.
And I lived there for two years above,
above Jackson's. And we train every day
with him. And like I said, I never left.
And uh, Greg asked me, he sat me
down after about, I don't know,
a couple of weeks of being there. He
said, man, I want you to be my 50 fiber.
And at that time he had a,
there's a list of 55 ers were nuts
that he had and I was like, wow,
fuck Greg Jackson,
who at the time was the man man,
right that the gym was
flicking a 90% winning great.
And he just, he's such a
knowledgeable, awesome dude man.
And to see where the gym was
to where the gym is now is,
it's like heartbreaking
to me to be honest. And I,
and you want to talk about loyalty,
which is the biggest thing
in this conversation that
we're having right now is
how they pick someone over me
through being loyal. I stuck by Greg.
Even when the gym started going down,
when Winkeljohn merged over,
all of the big pros left. It turned
into like a puppy mill. You know,
it wasn't for, for back when Greg
had it and it was its own school.
You couldn't turn up to a pro class. Like,
like some guy couldn't just come here,
knock on your door. Like you
said, you get Weirdos hero time.
Next thing you know he has shin pads
on the sparring. There's litter,
be at the new gym,
bumps come in off the street,
I swear to God and we'll fight these and
we'll come in and put stuff on a fight.
That's a true story.
You random bums off the street and uh,
that would never happen back in the
day. So Greg doesn't run it anymore? No,
he has.
He's like,
so out of the loop Winkeljohn runs
the entire thing and that's what,
what is Greg doing? He kind of stepped
back for a couple of years, man,
like kinda started doing other things
and just kinda got burned out I guess,
which is why I created the BMF ranch.
I needed somewhere to go and something
to do. So I created my office,
which is winks argument with me right
now saying you built your own place,
you don't ever come
here, blah blah. I said,
why don't ever come here because you
get the people you let in here is
outlandish.
Like anybody,
you pay $150 you can get on the
[inaudible] and spar with Holly Holmes.
You know what I mean? That's,
that's what it's come to down there.
And back in the day it was like
private and just us and good pros.
Everyone there for the same mission,
trying to, trying to get better, you know?
But I've talked to some
other people that are,
I don't want to name sure they've
said that when they go down,
their new guys will come in and is
literally a fight is a fight. It's a,
there's no, there's no, there's
no a, B, c class anymore.
It's like literally these guys come in,
they want to make a name on it.
He was sometimes when you're
towards the end of a fight camp,
you don't need those new guy. You don't
need that crazy sparring. Right. You need,
you need the guys you trust and
not some random guy. I don't know.
So it's just, it's Asinine me, man.
What they turned that place into that.
That still happens in MMA because you're
never going to find that in boxing and
boxing. All sparring is
control, controlled, bringing
the sparring partners,
you know, who you're
working with. So I mean,
we talk loyalty again to me with Greg,
his name is on that building. It's
not. It's wink Jackson Week, right?
Jackson fucking wink your names first.
Even when it came time to
pick a decision and they said,
we want to go with Perry.
Why the fuck didn't you stand?
Because Greg still with
me. He's like, yeah,
I'll just come to the ranch and
we'll sort this out. And I'm like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
You tell me I can't come
into the Jackson wink gym,
but you're going to back door and come
to my fucking house and we're going to
train to fight me while
Perry's there at the gym.
You see everything he does and then you're
gonna come and you're going to train
me. Not to mention you're holding
classes there and he's watching me.
You might not be training him to beat me,
but there's a lot of people there that
have trained me for fucking years.
So to me that was the point
I was saying like, man,
can we just not have them
there for this camp? I mean,
there's a lot of secrets that I, that
like inner secrets that I have, like Yo,
I'm, I'm fucking scared to death to
fight. Like that's that the say he can,
they can tell him like, or they tell them,
you know, go get cowboy mad, you know,
that's, he doesn't fight well when he's
pissed off. So fucking pissed him off,
poke out and poke the bear, piss him off,
get him out of his element and give him,
you know, the shit like this. Right.
So, and there's a lot of other things,
small dumb things that I do and tendencies
they've seen over over the year or 10.
Yeah. Right. Yeah. Um, to me
that's, it's very intimate.
The relationship between a coach and
a fighter is, is very, very intense.
So for someone to violate that
in that way, and you know,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with guys from a camp deciding to fight
each other and you've
got to work that out.
But for them to tell you that you can
[inaudible] I agree with you, right.
Figure it out. Right. Cause you go that
way. I W right. These are your times,
your hours back to each other,
right. Friends. But finding partners,
guy who just came in, like I said, I got
nothing against Perry. He's looking for,
he wants a home. Right? He's looking,
he felt like Jackson does. He's great.
I like that guy a lot. Stuff
that's not him. I mean, what
is he going to do? Right.
And, and I just said, hey, frank was
going to go and train with him wherever
I heard stories. He was looking
to go to Vegas anyways. I don't,
I don't have any idea, man. I
was just, I was just like, man,
can we just not do it for this fight? And
then Winkeljohn caught me on the phone.
Didn't you have the fucking balls or the
backbone to say it to my fucking face?
And I was right there with them. Call
them on the phone. Like, Oh, uh, yeah,
we're actually going to go with Perry.
You know,
he pays money and said again, it
comes back to the money. I'm like,
so Perry pays him a percentage and
you don't. I can see, hey Greg,
for my entire career I've ever been there
because I don't like Winkeljohn style
and I'm like his way.
He holds meds.
I don't like the way he trains
people different about what he does.
It's the same thing for rep, for you. For
me, for John Sam, they're all the exalted.
It's the cookie cutter. Everything's got
to the same and it never changes. It's,
I don't understand how you could be a
coach of the one of the greatest at one
time, the greatest Jim's on the planet,
you know, and then don't ever evolve.
Don't ever change and don't
run class. And it, to me, it's,
he just drove that place
into the ground, man. Turn,
literally turned it into a puppy mill.
It's only about making money.
And for you guys all,
I'm talking about a pug mill.
When someone has a dog and
they just fucking breed it
and sell puppies and breed
it and sell the puppies.
That's, that's what's happening.
That's the infrastructure of this gym.
Now let's talk about training there.
Let's talk about coaching,
right? Greg's supposed to be
the, the, the general, right.
I'm just a soldier. How come I have
to be now a general ANA soldiers?
That's the me. That's just fucking
up in my, in my career. I can't,
I need somebody to tell me what to do.
Tell me what not to do.
And I had to start my own school at
the ranch, bringing my own coaches.
But then now I'm making all of the
executive decisions when we're training,
what we're trained in, what we're doing.
And I'm not, I'm no longer just a soldier.
I'm having to fucking run
this whole thing. Um, that's
not mountain for fighters.
So problem for me too. I like, I liked it.
I'm a fucking super alpha male and I like
to communicate with my coaches and get
everything done in the guys that have a
fucking standing by me and I love him to
death, but I need someone to be like,
you know what? You crazy fucking bastard.
You go into hard, we're going to do
hyper office taper off as pumped. Right?
Or let's pick it up. Right? The,
the fucking fun fuck off part of your
life is taking over into your training.
Can we step it up a little bit?
Right. I need that. I need,
I need fucking direction.
I need today we're working on this,
not just me going in.
There's then ah,
let's fucking wrestling
today. Right? So, um,
you know what to do, but it's also nice
for someone else who knows what to do,
who's completely objective is standing
on the outside because there's bits,
I'm in this so long,
there's like,
I could literally Joe never spar from
now til the Perry fight and probably not
even do one Jiu Jitsu role and I would
be okay to fight like mentally. Right.
But that's probably not a very smart idea,
right?
Like it's not you at your
optimum. Exactly. Um,
so it's just, it's fucking Asinine
to me and the coaches down there.
So not only can somebody just ring
the doorbell and show up and train,
pay the money. You can pay the $25 a drop
in, or you pay the hundred 59 a month,
come to any class you want. But if you're
a coach, you can just coach the class.
It's that. It's that ass. And I do,
I see a new striking coach
or new wrestling coach or
new Jujitsu guy in there
twice a week probably,
and they're coaching the class.
Our rest main wrestling
coach of Jackson wink,
the greatest school in the fucking
world is a reception to a chiropractic
upstairs.
He's great as credentials.
Whereas he was a junior
assistant coach at a call.
It don't know the college name, who
got fired for selling the kid steroids.
That's our wrestling coach.
I had one of the greatest schools in
the world is a good coach and it was
terrible. He's fucking
God awful, terrible.
He watches videos on Youtube and tries
to teach people things that don't even
fucking work.
It's Asinine,
which is another who I had to hire my
own coach and bring them in. You know,
it's like, it's like, Whoa, wait,
what? And now they don't even drill.
They just go live and they want to
know why people get hurt every day.
It's like you can't just go in and
say, okay, and we're wrestling go.
So do you think that people just get burnt
out on doing things the right way and
they just, they just figure, look,
I'm just going to do this the way that
makes the most money? Well, I think,
man, I wish I had, I
had the answer for that.
I do because I'm not in that position to,
I'm not running a gym and that's,
I've never done that because I don't want,
to me showing up to class every
single day would wear me the fuck out.
Where's everybody?
It's got to.
But you should have an infrastructure
set in place that takes, especially if
you're the greatest at one
time, right? If you're winning,
percentages are in the eighties and
nineties and now they're in the 20s like I
don't, I have no clue what our, what
our rating record if the gym is,
but it's nothing like it used to be.
Right.
And it's fucking,
it's Asinine to me the way you were
doing as it, you have the BMF ranch,
right to everything set up.
You bring in all your sparring partners
and you would be doing all your training
out there. And how would Greg
interact? He would, he would, he,
we do their show up down at
Jackson's and spar cause they sell,
they're still bodies down there.
Right.
There's still guys would
show up down as the bar.
We'd bring all the guys down or
Greg would come up, you know,
three or four times a week to the ranch
and we do as far as your ranch from 50
miles bell. Okay. A good hour,
solid hour drive into the vast
Nolan's of New Mexico. Mexico.
Do you like living out there? I do.
I love it. I was fucking love it.
So I sold my house. I moved
here, I fucking planted roots.
Now I could never ever sell my place.
I'm stuck in New Mexico.
I'm moving back to Colorado. I'm a
buyer. I never saw it because I have,
this sounds like a crazy cult leaders
of anybody out there listening wants to
operate a colt.
I have the perfect alchemy.
We're going anchor you.
I got 40 acres, 40 acres,
plenty of rooms, buildings,
animals in your vicinity. Um,
oh well yeah. This might
be where we start. There's,
there's about an hour drive you can run
into milk and we have, we got antelope,
um, everywhere, which is
crazy thing about analog.
Did you know they don't jump fences,
they won't jump fences, right?
You can just literally corner
him into a, into a, into a meal.
Occasionally jump a fence. They've been
known to jump a fence occasionally.
It was very, very rare. You know,
they evolved before the ice age.
They evolve to get away from
Cheetahs. However, you're so smart.
That's what I want to know.
I'm not smart.
I just remember the dude is
fucking insane. There was a, a,
a mass extinction of giant land mammals.
It's somewhere around 12,000 years ago
in North America and before then there
was cheetahs.
There was actual North American cheetahs.
There was a North American lion
that's bigger than the African lion.
How about that shit.
Giant ass fucking line.
And that's where these fucking
things did you want another chu?
I swallowed it last time.
Whenever I meet people for
autographs, he's like, Kevin,
if you got Rogan to fucking take a
chill, not just take it. I swallowed it.
I didn't know what I was doing.
Like a man. Yeah. All right.
Round two. Here we go. To
what kind of,
it's a wintergreen Copenhagen Chin,
right under your lip.
You can put under your Chin if you want.
You take just a little one too late.
I don't want to take a big upper liver.